[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
hello and welcome to another trivia
charity stream that we've got going on
here I came spot play for all we've got
a special guest today
Jack Pattillo is joining us hey Jack
how's it going yeah thanks for having me
on I really appreciate it thanks for
being here how's it going
it's going well it's going well you know
it's you know it's it's I'm trapped
inside of course because you know you're
not supposed to leave your house right
now and it is hot as hell in Texas and
other nut it's great still haven't
watched Hamilton yet so I got that going
for me it's a long thing it's like three
hours all right so this is a charity
stream and we're doing movie trivia if
you missed movie trivia last time we are
doing 90's and 2000's mostly but we've
got some specific categories we're
covering today we're going to be
covering science fiction fantasy and
comedy and then we've got bonus rounds
we've got some lightning rounds for
movie posters and full movie tag lines
as well but this is a charity stream and
we're still raising money for black
lives matter and Cove in nineteen direct
relief so those donation links are right
here on the screen and also in the
description for the YouTube page and so
we are checking out the chat and I'll be
seeing who's donating and TAM will call
out when those donations come in but we
also have a new thing that we want to
announce is that we just opened up the
brand new and improved GameSpot's store
and all proceeds are going to charity
until the end of the month so as you can
see here we've got some cool stuff you
can buy some cool play for all merch
we've got hoodies t-shirts face masks a
touch tool skateboard and the official
play for all poster with the awesome art
you've seen on all of our graphics so
that's stored at game spot calm and once
again all proceeds go to charity until
the end of the month so get some cool
stuff for yourself and help charity so
that's really exciting we're really
excited to launch that and today we are
doing movie trivia so I will be your
quiz master and I'll be quizzing both
Jack and the GameSpot team we've got
of the games team and half representing
the entertainment team so we've got Tim
and Lucy representing games team and
Mike and Meg representing the
entertainment team hey guys you ready
so ready the two losers from the
entertainment team have come and
represent the entertainment team here
this is your thing up against the game
people pointing that out there I'm okay
at it I'm okay at it so I should we'll
see how it goes I'm curious about your
questions yes so I've described what
we're kind of doing but I also wanted to
mention that the chat can also earn
points so everyone on the panel can earn
their points but if no one in the panel
is able to answer the question the chat
can steal the point so last time we did
this check up 21 points so it's totally
possible you guys can do really well and
for every point that the chat earns I'm
going to donate to black lives matter
and Cove 19 Direct Relief and have those
donations matched by CBS so get those
points guys alright so we're gonna do
for every category we're gonna have I'm
gonna either bless three members of the
cast and you have to tell me what movie
it is so its name the movie from the
cast or name the movie from the synopsis
but that's where we usually start cuz
it's a little bit easier so Jack you're
our guest of honor do you want to be
sci-fi fantasy or comedy first I mean
let's go with sci-fi it's classified
let's do that I love it I love it
alright so to buzz in just in case
everyone hasn't done this before just
say your name cuz we don't have any
fancy buzzers like you're a Pokemon just
go for it and the louder and the more
enthusiastic the better but if I somehow
miss it or if the two of you did at the
same time we will all kind of vote and
be like I'm pretty sure I heard
so-and-so first okay okay alright so we
will start with sci-fi and we will do
name the movie from the synopsis first
alright here we go number one in the
colorful future a cab driver unwittingly
becomes oh yeah I think that was tan was
it III okay you know it was Jacqueline
tan
Jackie yeah okay that's gonna be Fifth
Element yes correct
[Laughter]
very nice okay here we go
number two for synopsis okay I was
writing down the score and TAM do we
have any donations we have yeah we
starting off we've got a Nawaz Iqbal who
donated $10 for kovat relief Nawaz has
been donating a lot recently thank you
and then Josh Brown donated $25 towards
black lives matter all right number two
a cyborg must now protect a woman's
teenage son for Jojo do you do that is
correct
number three the crew of a ship try to
evade an assassin sent to recapture one
of their members who is telepathic meg
Meg serenity number four a police
officer is brought out of that was a
gift
also it's Tam's birthday everyone please
say happy all right here we go next one
okay
agent J is sent to find agent Jack men
in black that is correct but we prefer
which one yeah which one do you think it
is you should read the rest of this in
Oakland okay so I got my guessing from
what it is right now
you said sent to find agent K so so
which one is it that's gonna be three
[Music]
yeah full description was agent Reyes
sent to find agent K and restore his
memory after the reappearance of a case
from Kay's past good call men in black 2
threes the best though Josh Brolin so
good in that in a future world
devastated by disease a convict is sent
back in time to gather information about
Meg Oh monkeys that is correct
okay time to shine Meg all right here's
the tough one I think as a modern-day
scientist Tommy is struggling with
mortality desperately searching for the
medical breakthrough that will save the
life of his cancer stricken wife Izzie
oh I will get the chat
I mean dizzy I will read it one more
time as a modern day scientist Tommy is
struggling with mortality desperately
searching for the medical breakthrough
that will save the life of his cancer
stricken wife Izzie
Jack Jack is that the fountain that is
correct
[Music]
2006 the fountain from Darren Aronofsky
oh if you guys are just joining us you
can also call out answers in the chat
that you're getting a lot of happy
birthday cams in the chat thank you
we're also taking donations for black
lives matter and Kobe 19 Direct Relief
those links are in the description and
also on the screen we got another $10
from no Asik powerful black man answered
the fountain
so I'm going to give because of the
delay I'm also going to give Nawaz a
point so chat get yeah chats on the
board with one point all right after the
founding here we go students suspect
that students suspect that their
teachers are aliens Tim the faculty
spike in Jessie was that something you
didn't know about the faculty I didn't
know it was shot in Austin Wow thank you
for that gift jack man and I've been
Austin twice and I didn't visit one of
them Stuart's a few films he's ever been
into yeah yeah all right here we go
the Alumni cast of a space opera
television series Jackie
Rajjo galaxy quest yes correct
[Laughter]
alright a rescue crew investigates a
spaceship that Kasim Lucy oh no alien
Joe no Rougeau event horizon correct
I guess that's place the movie
[Laughter]
absolutely sam neill
in the chat Whitney said I refuse to
wish him a happy birthday I wished it to
him two or three times last year
alright and a genetically inferior man
assumes the identity Joe Joe Gattaca I
noticed that we may get our snow I feel
like I'm being used as a punching bag
here I'm good like I've got the one
really okay I'm happy I don't usually
say name main characters unless there
obscures I'm leaving the first this one
blank blank and his allies race against
time before the machines discovered the
city of Zion a destroyed that was Tim
the matrix
Lucy Jack for Joe Russo a second Matrix
- reloaded correct I didn't get an
opportunity to define no but you didn't
say you didn't react to that Maxie
guessed if we're doing that oh you going
by the order of which the question was
first answered or are we getting a
chance to buzz in again no I'm going in
the order that people first posed it
okay okay so no need to do extra buzzes
a man struggles with memories of his
past with Joe Joe memento no oh yes yeah
I'll keep reading Joe now cannot answer
a man struggles with memories of his
past which include a wife cannot
remember a nightmarish world and no one
else seems to be waking a bag Meg
Jacob's Ladder incorrect a man struggles
with the memories of the Pat of his past
which include a wife he cannot remember
and a nightmarish world no one else
seems to be waking up from Oh Jack Jack
Dark City correct stark that was the
matrix before the matrix Jennifer
Connelly that's good one I recommend it
alright here we go in a future where a
special police unit is able to arrest
murderers
Oh Joe I know ready report correct
minority Roberta cakes in 2027 in a
chaotic world in which women have become
somehow infertile Tim Mad Max fury road
Lucy damn that is correct on the board
[Laughter]
all right we've got one two three four
left in this
yeah the son of a virtual world designer
goes looking for you see beggar Lucy oh
no I was gonna say buddy play one I'm
like Meg I mean I think Tron Legacy
correct Tron Legacy I just couldn't
remember if you guys are just tuning in
we're doing movie trivia this is sci-fi
we're wrapping up this line of
questioning and then we're gonna go to
name the movie from the cast and we've
also got donation links in the
description to donate to black lives
matter and copa90 and direct relief and
TAM we'll call out when we get those
donations coming in oh we got a few
answers here in the chat that got
children of men right quick good job -
James burden Nawaz and Ares good job
guessing those and Nawaz and Matthew
Hawking also got strong thanks cool all
right
a special military unit fights a
powerful out-of-control supercomputer
and hundreds of scientists who have
mutated into flesh-eating creatures
after a laboratory accident what
Lucy Lucy Resident Evil correct
that's a strange description for them
video games this is a remake the
Robinson family was going into space Joe
Joe Boston space correct with Matt
LeBlanc yes good cop Gary Oldman right
yes Heather Graham alright and the last
one for synopses a thief who steals
corporate secrets through the use of
dream sharing jack paycheck
Lucy inception corrects their corporate
secrets
[Laughter]
sci-fi synopses so leading the pack is
Mike with eight points and one for
second we have a three-way tie with Jack
Meg and Lucy all right on to the next
part of sci-fi which we are doing named
the movie from the cast before we do
that just a reminder donation links are
in the description below and we also
have a store now where we're selling
stuff that and all the proceeds are
going to charity so go to stores
gamespot.com to check that out I'm
buying the crap out of that skateboard
okay now we're gonna name the movie from
the cast so I'm gonna name three members
of the cast I'm trying not to call out
during the first one sometimes they're
in multiple sci-fi movies and you will
get stuck but you will if you tell you
buzz in you got to answer off that one
name all right cool and shout out to
people that are getting inception
correct in the chat James Byrd and names
don't matter and ste all got inception
correct here we go number one
Martin Freeman Sam Rockwell Jack Jack
Oh God so long thanks for all the fish
[Music]
yes number two don't guess on the first
name please Jeff Goldblum Bill Pullman
Randy Quaid Lucy Lucy Independence Day
correct independence just watch that
would have been terrible
oh that's speech from Bill Pullman
Joaquin Phoenix
Abigail Breslin Mel Gibson's Oh Roo Joe
signs that is correct
Oh forgot Joaquin was in the head right
he's back all right here we go
next one Elijah Wood tail Leone Morgan
Freeman
Lucy Lucy deep impact correct
why do what doesn't deep impact yeah the
only reason I know that is from the Lord
of the Rings special features because
Sean Anthony the only reason I know
that's great the first time the first
time Frodo appears in Lord of the Rings
it's on the DVD commentary I think it's
Sean Astin or Mary or Pippin and they
say hey he was in deep impact that's
when I say really is weird six degrees
of Kevin Bacon kind of connection not
yet but if folks wanna donate they can
use the two links there bit ly for last
year's - BLM or cheers - co vid to
donate yes please do
all right back to name the movie from
the cast next one Jude Law William Hurt
Haley Joel Osment
Jack Jack AI correct
I forgot yeah he's like he was a sexbot
gigolo bot yes correct
alright Denise Richards Jake Busey
Jack
oh god I'm doing it again right I know
it in thy head rico's Roughnecks wrong
oh god yeah on the spot it sometimes
that the name just escapes yeah all
right next one Vince Vaughn Vincent
D'Onofrio Jennifer Lopez Meg the cell
yeah that's the only one I'm gonna get
for this I don't know what that is it
was a total ass movie
it's so weird it's JLo plays a like a
psychologist who goes into them like
literal minds of like troubled children
but then she ends up having to sell it's
like very Silence of the Lambs like she
has to go song missing girl like a
serial murderer gets caught and they're
missing the girl that he took so she has
to go into his mind and it's like this
weird like MC Escher
it's really cool it's very good yeah all
right Laura Dern
Sam Jackson Lucy did you call my name
senpai Transkei Park yes correct
wait I was like Samuel chaplets yeah no
yeah he's alright
zoe saldana Sigourney Weaver Lucy have
you guys played the game of name two
characters from Avatar
other than Jake suleka do okay Kenny
name a third no second or third
highest-grossing movie of all time
okay remember Giovanni Ribisi was in
that movie we're gonna have to re-watch
avatar soon dollars you can't name three
characters from the Moon Park and it's
the more surreal experience in the world
it's like it's a bunch of like face
characters doing like shows and stuff
but all of the people walking around
them are like not engaging with them at
all and it's very uncomfortable like we
got yeah we got a $10 donation from
James Carr who's GameSpot's a current
editor
oh thank you James alright the next cast
Jodie Foster Matthew McConaughey James
Woods Jack good contact yes I can't
believe oh I love that movie he said
like Matthew McConaughey I was going all
right here we go
next one call urban Chris Pine Chris
Hemsworth
Lucy Lucy uh it is Star Trek the first
one yeah but when he was cast for Thor
that's the point of reference everyone
used was oh he was the guy who died in
the first five minutes discard Claire
Danes Arnold Schwarzenegger Chris Donna
Logan you see Lucy
oh no oh is it Terminator 3 yeah John's
love interest it's actually not a bad
movie I like the end of that movie
because it ends worth everything dying
like it's such a cool way to end it you
love to see it and then we got like
formal all right next one
Chris Evans Killian Murphy Michelle yow
Lucy Lucy sunshine correct oh my god how
did I not get that I love sunshine
mm-hmm all right next one Jude Law
Angelina Jolie Gwyneth Paltrow
Rochelle Rochelle is it hackers
incorrect
no dude woz not in hacker just a guess
dude law Angelina Jolie winneth Paltrow
I will look at the chat and see if
anyone got it man
Jude Law has been a lot of sci-fi movies
and I feel like when a pod room is not
that's every time you every time you say
dude why just want to say Gattaca
Gattaca Mikey Mikey O'Leary and James
Burton got it in the YouTube chat and
Jenny she's all Sky Captain and the
World of Tomorrow - good job - chat I
will also check over on the switch and
see if they got it they did not okay but
good job - the YouTube chat for getting
a point for sure all right so next one
Elizabeth Banks Michael Rooker Nathan
Fillion
Lucy Lucy got into the galaxy vol 2
incorrect Jack Rayburn incorrect mmm
good guess
yeah the year 2006 meg Meg sliver
correct yeah I was like with any cameos
or something yeah they were all main
characters yeah they were all in that
movie Wow those James Gunn right yeah so
close Guardian yeah with the cameos
cause I think Miley Cyrus was a cameo in
yeah there's a he's in the first
guardians he's one he's the the big dude
that Groot shoves his fingers up his
nose yeah yeah that's correct
so I just needed Elizabeth Banks and
that would have been a correcting last
one for name the cast near the movie
from the cast Will Smith Bridget
Moynahan Shia LaBeouf
Jack oh god the robot movie the robot my
robot yes I know I've got the
information it takes a second to unlock
I have to like go through a few chambers
to get to it all right good job to the
chat room getting slither one two three
four five someone just put a snake emoji
six seven eight people got it right good
job
all right we are moving on to the next
category uh the current leader is micro
Joe Mike would you like comedy or
fantasy next what error in every
sticking me with that comedy then before
we do that we've got ten dollar donation
from Matt Hawking again for black that's
now thank you Matt thank you Matt
Hawking thank you so much for donating
multiple times as well my donate say
don't Skyrim mods Elia thank you so much
if you guys want to be cool like Matt
there is donation links in the
description and they're also right there
on the screen for you for black lives
matter and covin 19 Direct Relief and
also just continue uh playing along with
us in the chat because if the chat gets
questions right we're donating a dollar
to each cause and then having that
matched all right and then Nawaz and ste
Punisher also got a Roebuck correct good
job okay so we're moving on to comedy
these are 90s and 2000's comedy films so
that should help you a little bit we're
gonna start with synopsis a major
question chasidy
for teenage boys enter a pact to lose
their virginity by prom you see Lucy
American Pie corrects American Pie star
trek inception up all stuff that I've
watched with Gregg and Jenn very
recently I kind of forget the plot to
that yeah I forgot that those without
movie is about yeah
would've been too obvious I'd made that
a plaque question right number two
mistaken for a millionaire of the same
name
a man seeks restitution for Joe Rochelle
Big Lebowski that is correct
two aimless middle-aged loser is still
living at home are forced against their
we seen Lucy step brothers that is
correct
[Laughter]
okay next one blank is a hit with the
plastics the a-list grew sick Oh Lucy
Mean Girls that is correct
okay private Joe Bowers the definition
of an average American is selected by
the Pentagon to be the guinea pig for a
top-secret hibernation program Jack
Rochelle idiocracy Mike judges ours he's
one of our guys yeah it's a if you
haven't watched it lately it is the
concept behind the movie was fantastic
and a spot-on but the movie itself is
bad Anna man remember the remember the
bite movie they all watch okay at the
end of his career a clueless fashion
model is brainwash he's right Lucy
Zoolander yes correct by one chance
guilt-stricken after a job gone wrong
hitman ray and his partner await orders
from their ruthless boss and champion
Joe in Bruges how else would I pronounce
that in Brogan's these three buddies
wake up from a bachelor party in Las
Vegas
see schoolin yeah a puppeteer discovers
a portal that leads literally and Jack
Being John Malkovich yes it's so weird
the word puppeteer definitely threw me
off right all right a goofy detective
specializing in animals shows Lucy
Ace Ventura yes
what is the full name in the sequel yeah
all right
a 1960s secret agent is brought out of
crime Joe Joe Austin Powers correct here
we go a weatherman finds himself in
uh-huh now as I did my time when I lost
it
anyone buzzing engineer was anyone else
buzzing in yeah Jack I'll go I'll take a
shot
is it the weatherman no okay anyone else
continue with both continuing okay so a
weatherman finds himself inexplicably
living the same day over Lucy
Groundhog Day correct yes
she's a weatherman all right yeah it's
gonna be a cold one today gonna check on
the chat got thank you too Toby for
getting Being John Malkovich correct
nawaz got a spent aura so did gray fox
Austin Powers was guest friendly by SCE
Punisher Richie also got Austin Powers
good job guys donation links are on the
screen and in the description below so
thank you you know $5.00 from anonymous
we said love the trivia that was for
covered relief and then we've got $10
from David Trang it doesn't say anything
just in dollars jack is the Weathermen a
Nick Cage movie yes yes I had the same
thought but then I thought that's not a
comedy sorry
not maybe throw man's economy I don't
remember the poster for but I don't
actually remember them I remember it
being not funny
so so one third of all so I just wanted
to mention again that the GameSpot's
door is open so if you would like to
donate and also get something cool for
yourself store gamespot.com has all the
cool playful merge that you could want
all profits go to charity until the end
of the month so there you have it right
there you got a mask you've got a cool
hoodie t-shirts skateboard touch tool
and the official poster so check that
out
store gamespot.com cool all right next
in order to inherit his fed-up father's
hotel Empire and Rochelle Billy Madison
correct we could probably go back and
forth start at the top hopeless dweeb
Elliot Richards is granted seven wishes
by the devil to snare Alison the girl of
your dreams jack bedazzle yes Brendan
Fraser Elizabeth Hurley right yes in
that movie so stylish all right
a 35 year old video game tester has
moved in with Regina Jackie Brousseau
how much boy correct underrated Isaac
you Dante okay all right next one a male
nurse meets his girlfriend's parents
before proposing Jack meet the ha wait
is it not Meet the Fockers that's gonna
let this later one Oh God
meet parents yes those the other parents
yes
devastated Peter takes a Hawaiian
vacation and/or you seen Lucy Forgetting
Sarah Marshall Peter
six unemployed steel workers form a male
striptease act jack
full monty all right
a listless and alienated teenager
decides to help his new friend with the
class presidency in their small Western
listen Lucy I'm Napoleon Dynamite Koretz
I wonder if that movies still funny yeah
did you ever see gentlemen Broncos no it
was there was the follow-up as the same
director directed that it's got Jemaine
Clement in it and Samwell it's weird
it's like they took weirdest parts of
Napoleon Dynamite and made a whole movie
of it it's it's worth a watch twenty
self-proclaimed stuntman rod Kimble is
[Laughter]
correctly arguing with the rest of the
entire team years that hot rod is a
better movie than pop star never sells
they're both good one is clearly better
one it's really better than the better
one is hot a meme egg see all day come
on because there with a chat if you like
pop star or a hot rod better and we'll
have that count for something yeah
please vote hot rod thank you I think
they were guessing a career Tony I'm
counting them there they're part of the
poll yes they're part of the next one a
Korean American office worker and his
Indian American stoner friend Jack Jack
me up I was just a office space but
that's not it so no Joe Aaron Kumar Go
to White Castle
correct mm-hmm I do hope there's an
office-based questioning here though
I asked about it last for last trivia
yeah yeah so there's not too many
repeats here except for the faculty okay
Oh gray fox said meg is right in all
caps thank you it's so funny
Scot nerd also said hot rod is better
Wow I'll die
she also said ha Pam you better Wow
these opinions guys I love pops all
correct I'm right near there like Burt
Chris hater popped into the chat to say
hot rod is not better than Chris's vote
counts for 10 no okay next question
the adventures of high school and junior
high students on the last day of school
in May 1976 Joe Jack Joe I'm confused
that is correct also filmed in Austin I
know Austin Phil man keep it coming I'm
not getting it I'm not gonna get right
[Laughter]
all right jack super tubers that is
correct
all right a skilled London police
officer is translates Lucy
hot foes that is correct you're a father
vows to get a son a turbo man action
figure Jesus Jack jingle all the way
yeah I just watched that last Christmas
it still holds up talk about that movies
capitalism again incredible documentary
I've only seen bits and pieces of it
actually watched the whole thing you'll
fall in love with Schwarzenegger that
dude is he's so he's so charismatic
all right he's
my diploma from SF State because he was
the governor I was like I got a graduate
as soon as possible he's gonna be an
office all right last one for synopses a
malfunctioning time machine at a ski
resort Lucy again we watched this like
two weeks ago that's all I know about it
that's true because they referenced that
in in game they mention Hot Tub Time
Machine which Sebastian is one of our
900 III movie it's a great easter egg
guys that wraps up just that part of
trivia we're gonna move on so you name
the movie from the cast but before we do
just a reminder that we are raising
money for black lives matter and Cove in
nineteen direct relief those links are
right there on the screen and also in
the description below if you are on the
YouTube chat right now and also if you
would like to get something and donate
at the same time please go to our store
right there you can see what we've got
we got t-shirts we got a hoodie we got a
mask a cool skateboard a touch tool and
the official poster so just go right
there to store that gamespot.com that's
store gamespot.com all right now we're
going to name the movie from the cast
we've got 20 questions here same deal
gonna name three actors try not to guess
on the first one a lot of these people
are in multiple comedies but I will give
you a bonus point if you guess it on one
name maybe yeah but it could you only
get one guess though so giving everyone
else a shot by guessing it wrong all
right first one Luke Wilson
Vince Vaughn well Ferrell Joe Joe
wedding crashers incorrect oh nothing
meg Meg anything Oh Meg Oh No
Lucy Lucy old school yes
all of these people are in there Lucy
and Mike are tied now it's funny all
right Amy smart Anna Faris Ryan Reynolds
Lucy Lucy waiting so close Amy Smart is
not in that one Anna Faris and Ryan
Reynolds are Michelle Rhee Joe the House
Bunny or something like wasn't there
like you know Ryan Reynolds is not in
that one Chuck
Jack just friends yes Anna Faris in the
House Bunny though yes is the house in
person got sued because apparently she
didn't do all of her publicity stuff
that she was signed on to do did she
leave a lawsuit I don't remember
whichever whichever movie she was in it
was like the same time same pink mm it
was a it was a that was a because I'm
going to give chat a point as well
because Noah's Mikey O'Leary and put
them all got and ste Punisher all got
just friends correct cool here we go
next one Brittany Murphy Paul Rudd
Lucy Lucy clueless yes whoa Brittany
Murphy okay Joseph gordon-levitt Julia
Stiles you see Lucy 10 Things I Hate
About You yeah these all the movies that
we watched over and over here we go uh
Rachel McAdams isla Fisher Christopher
Walken
Rochelle Joe that one's wedding crashers
thank you
I need be in there somewhere Nathan Lane
Gene Hackman Robin Williams Rochelle
Rochelle patch Adams
no Jack The Birdcage yes that is Helen
that was uh it was a guy who he was
introducing his parents to his
girlfriend's parents and his dad was gay
and rod Williams and Nathan Lane are
together all right
Cary Elwes Richard Lewis Dave Chappelle
Lucy Lucy oh wait wait
Rochelle laiá laiá nope Jack Robin Hood
men in tights Oh Kerry Ellis yeah my
beautiful first love carry the thrown
out song literally Princess Bride right
now it's shoutout to james burden Mikey
O'Leary Richie EJ shizzle forgetting
Birdcage right Richie oh so the birdcage
is great please watch ASAP it's almost
all right next one that was Matt Dillon
Cameron Diaz Ben Stiller
Jack Jack there's something about Mary
yes nice
it's about Dylan all right Emma Stone
Michael Sarah
Lucy Lucy super bad yep
okay Seth Green ethan embry jennifer
Love Hewitt Jack can't hardly wait yeah
and your mic working I should not be
here we got a $10 donation from Vishal
Patel who says great stream great cause
also shout-out to Achievement Hunter and
then I got a we got $25 and 69 cent
donation towards black lives matter from
Ron John's nice thank you thank you
thank you if you guys want to donate
donation links are on the screen and in
the description on YouTube all right
next one digest you can't hardly wait I
mean yes uh Lauren Holly Jeff Daniels
Jim Carrey Jack Jack Dumb and Dumber
yeah
Michael Caine Sandra Bullock Benjamin
Bratt loose daddy Lucy Miss Congeniality
film in Austin the building that
achievement is housed in is the studio
they shot Miss Congeniality and we have
a picture of Sandra Bullock on our door
like there's like movies filmed in the
studios like and that one was filmed in
our building all right
Pierce Brosnan Sally Field Robin
Williams
Lucy Lucy mrs. Doubtfire mm-hmm Rose
nagari knee short end of the stick in
that film okay next one Shannen Doherty
Jason Lee Ben Affleck Sunni Jack
Mallrats
yeah good guy okay next one Seann
Williams Scott
Breckin Meyer Tom Green Rochelle
Rochelle the only Tom Green movie I
could think of off the top of my head
Freddy got fingered no oh you know what
I know what it is
Road Trip yeah it is cuz he's gonna
music because when you said Freddy got
fingered I was like that was a spinoff
yeah mr. roadtrip was also filmed in
Austin party they go to they go to the
University of Austin which is you - yeah
like they shot at you take I like cuz
it's like when you're watching something
on Amazon Prime and use the x-ray
features yeah really commentary running
in the back of my head at all time if
you want to talk about cannibal to
musical I can talk to you about that for
days okay next one Hugh Grant Andie
MacDowell
Rowan Atkinson Lucy Liu
full weddings in a funeral correct I'm
British monumental middle-aged mother
also in love actually know that caught
me for a second yeah but she's don't
think she is no but Ron Atkinson is yeah
yeah okay Chris Evans Jaime Pressly
Randy Quaid meg Meg thank God heavens
knowledge has got it okay good job
Danny McBride James Franco Seth Rogen
Rizzo Joe it could be so many movies but
which one specifically yes okay okay
Molly Shannon Rochelle no way I'm gonna
shoot my shot superstar no good guess
all right uh Janeane Garofalo maggie
jack meg what american summer yes
another great film yes all right Steve
Carell Mark Wahlberg Tina Fey I know I
know the concepts of movie I can't think
of the name of it though Jack date night
yeah
all I could think was not mister missus
that was yes and mister the rock mmm I
will also wait for the chat if they got
it right I will give the point yes James
Burton got it right in the chat with the
delay so chat also gets
another point points now good job and
podem 11 and Nawaz and eg shizzle and
Scott nerd collector good job getting
that right chat has a point and darkman
119 on twitch chat as well thanks okay
so that was comedy so we are onto
fantasy I kind of got a chance hi how
about you deleting here we go so mike
has 22 Lucy has 27 so Lucy's leading
since 27 jack has 21 that's our top
three okay what do I have I've no
watched any of those films 18 of them
for name the movie from the synopsis
these also include 80s movies so it's
gonna be a little tougher because you
have a wider through 2019 is that
because there were more fantasy movies
in the eighties it kind of okay okay
here we go a young man must stop the
Lord of Darkness from destroying
daylight and marrying a woman Jack
legend yeah Tom Cruise man maybe Tom
Cruise Tim Curry in that also as loan
from Ferris Bueller's Day Off you say
that just sounded like a generic fantasy
young man let's start and stop an evil
guy a blacksmith teams up with an
eccentric pirate to save his love the
governor's daughter from former pirate
allies of the capellini Lucy
to the Caribbean which one the first one
okay the body of M hotep is shipped Lucy
- Lucy the mummy which one first one
incorrect Tim mommy - yep
correct know what it's called what's it
called
mommy returns yes all right I'll see you
guys in about 20 all right
sixteen-year-old Sarah is given 13 hours
to solve a blank and rescue her big
brother Meg labyrinth yeah a nice forget
about the baby baby during her during
her family's move to the suburbs a
sullen ten-year-old girl wanders into a
world ruled by gods witches and spirits
and where humans are changed into beasts
Lucy Lucy Oh No spirited away yes we
have Miyazaki yet yes guys we are also
still donations to black lives matter
and Koba 19 Direct Relief those links
are on the screen for you right now
and also in the description so please
donate and tam will read out the
donations women we got a $5 donation
from anonymous thank you thank you thank
you alright next one we just did an
afterlife therapist and his daughter
made a friendly young ghost Joe Jack
Casper the Friendly Ghost
yes and it's like it the creepy movie
when you watch him now the big way we're
talking about how Casper died because
his dad bought him a sled and he loved
it too much and he got sick wrecked me
yeah
I remember thinking that movie was so
cool cuz the cozier Iggy's name was cat
and I was like I thought that it was
just like the coolest name that a girl
can have ever when I was like eight cute
she's so good Addams Family I love it
alright here we go
a troubled boy dives into a wondrous
fantasy world through the pages of a
mysterious book bag meg neverending
story yeah oreag master or four kids
travel through a wardrobe to the landing
screaming Lucy Chronicles of Narnia
full name The Lion the Witch and the
Wardrobe yeah they made Prince Caspian
what's your answer tell us your answer
Ricky's like Ben Burns is amazing give
me food Ricky gets one point and a dream
okay next one story a genius and her
wonderful Joe I told her yeah amazing
stage show the there's a plane it's
incredible I've never seen the play I
didn't realize the the girl from
hereditary was Matilda onstage for a
long time
oh she why there's no only thing she was
known for before Matilda ready Terri
she's also I'm tick-tock goodness she's
very good nice she's very charismatic I
interviewed her for hereditary she was
like so different from her character in
that movie use while it's great good
Jack and Mike are tied now that's bad
all right next question
I didn't tell dokay here we go uh I
should probably leave tractor names out
blank and blank lead the world of men
against blanks army to draw his gaze
from blank and blank as Tim Lord of the
Rings which one Fellowship of the Ring I
think correct Lucy Return of the King
correct
[Laughter]
they're all the same no pop stop it all
right
a group of young misfits called blank
discover an ancient map and set up rock
star there and back again at a
top-secret research facility in the
1960s a lonely janitor forms a unique
relationship with an unfit bridge and
fibia screecher right I think that was
Lucy she met yes current journey
all right so we're into the arena of the
20 teams here
yeah this is all over fantasy it's just
like I'm just reaching for wherever
there's feces basically starting from
1980 a prince cursed to spend his days
as a hideous monster sets out to regain
his human Tim actually no I was gonna
say Shrek but that is not eating the
Beast yes correct
Tim I don't know the answer but we got a
donation for a mr. Bruck amantes oh
thank you sir hav so the love trivia day
you guys are all awesome chastity also
killing it as a host Jack Highlander
yeah immortal swordsman should give him
that one away and yes that Orihime
yeah when an unconfident young woman is
cursed with an old body by a spiteful
witch meg Meg Isles Moving Castle yeah
[Laughter]
looking to a lot of merry-go-round of
light on YouTube like played by like
limbic covers which is the most soothing
thing in like the entire world the Beast
right a lot of Highlander guesses in the
chat from Mikey O'Leary Ezra Scott nerd
eg Matt Hawking and a swan thank you
thank you thank you all right here we go
next one a curious youngster moved to
Salem where he struggles to fit in
before awakening a trio of diabolical
Maggie's Meg hocus-pocus yes
Trio trio Salem trio yep
a teenager discovers he's the descendant
of a Greek god and sets meg Meg Percy
Jackson and the lightning thief I was
waiting for it you got it it's the
lightning thief all right and last one
when a massive fire kills their parents
three children Jojo series of
unfortunate events yes correct Emily
Browning yes I was gonna say it's crazy
like the Netflix series they just cloned
the the younger version of the girl and
broader - the Netflix series yeah I
haven't seen the Netflix version is it
good it's pretty good Neil Patrick
Harris is great oh I'll bet I love those
books shadow - Nawaz who got Percy
Jackson correct as well that was a tough
one all right on to the next part which
is named the movie from the cast in
order fantasy films as I said before
from 1980 through the 2000s okay here we
go Mandy Patinkin
Lucy Lucy The Princess Bride yes do I
get to cuz I got it on the first yes you
do
[Laughter]
come on you say Mandy Patinkin and I
think homeland how weird is that
here we go okay Dennis Quaid Sean
Connery dina meyer lucy lucy dragon ha
yeah yeah other than Starship Troopers
all's like what is dina meyer Bennett
right I'm Sean Connery cuz that movie
was on in the UK like most Sundays in
heart lunchbox yeah I mean at Disneyland
Paris they have like a backlot tour and
there's a dragon heart portion of the
back lots which is just a destroyed
London cityscape with fire breathing
like that's it there's like 14 sequels
like directive VHS sequence just kept
coming
I haven't seen any of them I've seen the
second one or the third one because
there's wine which is the guy from
malcolm in the middle' good Francis he's
the main guy in one of really great
Masterson's right yeah yeah prepotent in
the middle yeah I would have been during
at the time wild yeah like raise your
hand if you wanted that guy to be your
older brother I just have a microphone
why he puts like the entire pack of
peeps also wanted Cranston could be your
dad my dad still do great job great job
alright next one Christina Ricci
Christopher Walken Johnny Depp
Jack Jack oh my god it's it's the The
Barber of Fleet streaks or Sleepy Hollow
yeah
I changed movies okay this is stuff Sam
Worthington Liam Neeson ray Fiennes
Lucy Lucy Clash of the Titans yeah a guy
that I used to go to school with hit me
up on Facebook randomly like seven years
after we left I hadn't spoken to him
since and he was like oh hey I got a new
tattoo do you want to see it and he was
like I think you'll like it
and I was kind of like oh okay sure
facebook video he has an entire sleeve
of the the gods and whoever from Clash
the Titans but it's ray Fiennes and Sam
Worthington and uma Thurman why did you
think that you would appreciate that in
particular just going down everyone like
look right now it's a dark man 1:19 and
the switch dad who got Clash of the
Titans right also we've got a sequel did
it say more than Garth Sam where they
then went through like a rash of movies
where he was handed a star like yeah
where the first one came out he made
like four and then the person came out
they're like oh this guy's horrible and
they've never done anything ever again
yeah in the end okay here we go
Dustin Hoffman Julia Roberts Robin
Williams
jack-jack yeah in my head I was like my
Centennial man hook you and McGregor
Helena bonham-carter
Billy Crudup oh my god oh my god
Lucy Lucy Oh
7:5 oh my god I've seen it oh I know
wait no [ __ ] I don't think somebody fell
the goldmine wait we can get points for
wrong guesses if your chassis next time
we do this you gotta establish the
faculty let's see if the check on it I
will check its torque
dream in 119 got it in the twitch chat
it is big fish cry so hard
also Mikey O'Leary and asthma also got
big fish correct good job you guys
CBeebies late I know I did this last
time but it was the other dog last time
baby's legs moving right here she's
freaking out right now
all right here we go next one val kilmer
Warwick Davis Juicy Lucy uh-oh my god
willow yeah sucks right what do you know
you know it is you gotta unlock
how are we doing on donations Tim we
call a $25 donation for Kobe relief from
Dustin Giovanelli so much if you guys
want to donate
we've still got just under an hour left
of this stream so go over to those links
that you see on the screen they're also
in the description if you're on YouTube
all right on to the next one here we go
ooh did willow already okay Claire Danes
Robert De Niro Michelle Pfeiffer meg Meg
artist yeah Wow
okay fantastic movie I like baby Matt
Murdock is in that Heath Ledger Matt
Damon Lena Headey meg Meg Knight's Tale
incorrect dammit oh god I know it
Heath Ledger Matt Damon Lena Headey
Haiti Jack Jack the Brothers Grimm yeah
I truly have never seen any fantasy
movie in my life right I watched
labyrinth once james marsden Amy Adams
Susan Sarandon meg Meg enchanted yes
thank you
thanks pastic movie I love it James
Martin's got pipes yeah Nicole Kidman
Ava Greene Christopher Lee Daniel Craig
Jeff bridge oh the Golden Compass yes it
is I trying to remember which group that
way which version was called His Dark
Materials that was they the film was
named after the first book
all right Paul Giamatti Jeffrey Wright
Bryce Dallas Howard oh my god
Lucy Lucy the village incorrect you're
on the right track
damn it come on you know I know it's
like in my head I'm trying to picture
Paul Giamatti and like garb
Lucy's on the right track Asha Milan
yeah name another one of those in the
water
yes correct okay and the chat also gets
the point for guessing it before
everyone with Bryce Dallas Howard the
lady in the water
she sure is one M on roast you a little
which is my favorite point goes to
Indian Waldo on Twitch for lady in the
water also David James Michael des Juan
Ezra all got it right in the Twitter
YouTube chat as well nice all right one
last one here Anne Hathaway Johnny Depp
me about you Kafka
Lucy Lucy uh it is Alice in Wonderland
that is correct
oh my god minashi cuffs go was my first
celebrity interview and I had to learn
how to say her name and get a say what
would it say it
Mia Wasikowska was my first silvery
interview and I want to get it right
what was it for Ellen no for Jane Eyre
with Cary Fukunaga as a director right
yeah he was my second interview yeah I
remember we talked about Cary Fukunaga
but I did not remember that not mess up
how she kept Scott and Fukunaga in one
interview I did it alright so that
concludes the fantasy part of named the
cast so we are going on to our lightning
rounds so we've got about 45 minutes
left and for our lightning rounds we
have movie
posters and tag lines we're gonna do
posters first so Eric Tay working behind
the scenes please prepare those movie
posters he's a visual test so if you're
not good with casts you might be good
with posters this could be year round so
if we need to kill time talk about our
dogs meg where did Beasley go right
behind me he's just there he is a good
boy
yeah he likes to like I have all these
stuffed animals because they're my bed
is too far away from the wall so if
there's not something there he'll fall
into the crack wall but he now is like
claimed it as his little heap so I
enjoyed when he was briefly right behind
you staring directly into the camera
yeah sometimes when I was very very much
asleep my dog is looking at squirrels
out the windows oh she's an Australian
Shepherd mixed with God knows what we do
from a local shelter and so but she was
raised by my two older cats so she's
pretty much a cat that's just 50 pounds
and she's awesome looking at squirrels
but not barking is a foreign concept to
my dogs yeah that she'll climb on the
back of couches it's funny you can hear
me we are ready for posters cool all
right let's start it yeah ready guys so
yeah just just call out your name as
soon as you can tell Meg Meg Star Wars
Episode one Episode one no this is
pottery the Phantom Menace scoop that
was wow yeah I would not have got that I
don't know sir work hey you got that you
know that was really impressive that you
gotta just on an i I liked our thought
if he's got a good vibe yeah all right
Megan thanks
okay next one job you see Jack airplane
yeah I play in the movie what is that
what's the category on this one is it
just everything this is all genres
between eight 80s 90s and 2000's and
22news um no not for posters I sell okay
time yeah all right next
Lucy Lucy scary movie yeah oh yeah I
thought that was gonna be a
bait-and-switch
good job yes Lucy Lucy move on yeah
Horace okay next one Jack Meg Jack D T
mm-hmm that is et for a bonus point what
year did that come out Clem a Meg 88
Lucy 86 no too late for Joe resume 84
mm-hmm
Tammy onna guess I think I know what
accent what are you free so close it's
1982 no points when I was a child when I
was convinced it was haunted I like it
was very here's a dumb trivia knowledge
that I have for some stupid reason the
et ride is the only original attraction
left at Universal Studios Orlando yeah
like a chess copy of Spielberg like
giving you the like pre-emptive fried
stuff to they read they have redone in a
couple times I don't know what I would
literally was just like last year for
the opening of the Harry Potter Hagrid
I think clearly I bailed out in pirate
Potter world and immediately was like 80
riot oh boy but it's still definitely
like the like 4x3 like garbage be a test
of Spielberg I'm giving chat the point
eg shows 1882 correct nice Jack Jack
x-men yes
that's James Martin in the background
Wow alright next poster
Lucy Lucy How to Lose a Guy in 10 days
no Jack Jack she's all that yeah yeah
I'm an unnecessary knowledge of a dumb
romantic comedy Matthew Lillard for Joan
yeah Back to the Future yeah oh my god
as much solid thanks for not doing the
sequel next Lucy I don't Lucy Chi story
mm-hmm those clouds man Amy's bedroom
wallpaper man yep all right next one
Lucy Lucy duck night correct oh my god
okay
well done there it is next I've never
seen that image before in my life I've
seen it everywhere
well that's character posters they
didn't problem in yeah
Jack Jack Empire Strikes Back correct
there it is there's that taun taun what
year was that 1980 all right next one
Luke Meg
Lucy Oh No got it yep yeah Sandra
Bullock movie all right I know someone
that thought they were gonna see 28 days
and which is all me we're here all right
next one
Jack Jack The Addams Family
correct there they are
[Music]
next one's gonna read to you back again
weird is relevant what a good tagline
that is a good you see lucky Lucy
Breakfast Club yeah yeah yeah classic
next you see a girl Lucy else
yeah all right before we move to the
next one I just want to shout out that
we are still taking donations to black
lives matter and Cove a 19 Direct Relief
those links are in the description below
just so you know
Tamm do we have any new donations we've
got $10 from Ethan gerund for both black
lives matter and Direct Relief elf was
the last great Christmas movie right has
there been one since then that was like
you considered a great Christmas film I
think yeah in terms of like great
Christmas film I want to say it elf was
probably the last one yeah I can't think
of a Christmas movie yeah nothing became
a staple I was one of the suckers when
it saw last Christmas the Khaleesi
yeah yeah yeah with Emilia Clarke yeah
yeah Wow that
movie not good the ending I read about
what the ending was and kind of that you
pick up about five minutes into the
movie you're like it can't be that easy
right
oh no it is my wife gets the twist from
the trailer yeah you know she's like oh
I bet ya know yeah so you know grateful
anyway I'm not a good one next poster
Jeffrey go Jack you're in Loathing in
Las Vegas next one Lucy Lucy a Little
Mermaid mm-hmm Finding Nemo what yeah
it's a in the in the castle zoom in on
the dinky coward I'll believe you okay
look it up later all right
next poster Maggie
Jack The Incredibles yeah next poster
meg Meg Sam bought incorrect no Little
Rascals yeah weird Macaulay Culkin
look-alike in the bottom right no
seriously okay next one Lucy Lucy
Bladerunner yeah oh my god I have I have
blade when a prince like right here
Lucy have you seen all the videos from
from fourth of July weekend of people
flying drones over Los Angeles and then
putting the music from the opening of
Blade Runner where it's flying over just
a next poster
Lucy Lucy Lord of the Rings two towers
correct
Wow there it is
was that a gas or did you know James
Gollum doesn't really have a presence in
the first one and you kind of have the
two towers starts with the flashback and
yeah I'm not proud of that one that I
was obsessed with for what Jack Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles movie surprisingly
holds up this one right here actually
holds up today the second and third one
were trashed but this one's actually
pretty good let's give Chris hanger a
chance to respond Ninja Turtles fan all
right next one Lucy Lucy uh Nightmare on
Elm Street yes impressive why are we not
doing Shawn resent this is the lightning
round
all his 80s 90s 2000s ninja turtles in a
Nightmare on Elm Street those are side
by side of them alright next poster
please make them Lucy please gem yes
okay still haven't watched the end here
the airbrushed poster what was the
Michael Jordan Bowles documentary called
oh the last dance yeah I saw him see the
end of that that's good you watch the
third couple it was really good yeah I
watched that whole thing great
alright next poster Jack you see
ghostbusters mm-hmm Lucy Greg is gonna
be a Shane with you take that one do you
know how many proton packs it in my
closet full sized ones but there was a
bunch of other stuff we've got like the
whole Playmobil set basically everything
goes busters and suits and stuff -
they're all in any other closet in my
room I got the Lego fire house right
there it is a great set got the ecto-1
there - alright next poster it's like
we're nerds
Jack Joe that is Tomb Raider yes Wow
looking it I've never looked at this
poster so closely but it looks like that
belt is photoshopped onto her yeah it
really does especially it looks like
that's not her like that they've ever
faced somebody else
doesn't matter iconic stop maintaining
greatness next poster Lucy Lucy Indiana
Jones
Raiders of the Lost Ark it is reading
The Lost Ark it's not alright they not
change that in retrospect like a new
like a new hope oh [ __ ]
we Joe how many how many 24 points do I
get for that one
next closer Joe The Life Aquatic yeah I
believe chronic booster behind me hey
forget that wound if I was in that movie
great alright and the last one Lucy Rick
what gave it away it has a lot of
texture on it and I don't like it
alright good job so Lucy is leading the
pack with 52 points my goodness
Jesus alright then jack is in second
with 41 and then Mike is in third with
30 so we're gonna toss back to donations
here so please donate to black lives
matter this the link is on the screen or
Cove in nineteen direct relief link is
on the screen as well or in the
description you're still collecting
donations for another half hour while
this stream goes on and also if you want
to get some merch and donate the
GameSpot's store is open store
gamespot.com where you can get all sorts
of cool play Frommer's we've got
t-shirts we've got hoodies masks
skateboards the official poster and a
key tool so check that out and all
proceeds go to charity
alright on to our final lightning round
are you guys ready for some movie
taglines
Mike and Meg as you remember from last
time some of these are written very
badly but I picked ones that are
hopefully have some kind of clue in them
there were a lot of ones I'm just like
no one's gonna get this and I just
scrapped him but we've got at least 41
of these I have 5 extra bonus questions
if we guess them too fast but these are
movie tag lines these are all between
the years 1990 and 2010 and the bonus
ones will be more recent if we get to
those all genres all genres in 1990 and
2010
all right here we go first one you don't
get to 500 million friends without
making a few magazines the social
network that's correct
oh my movie is the social network you're
a demolition man bang yes it's her pop
star I tell people doesn't always think
I'm crazy but for like the longest time
in college I would just leave the social
network on like while I select cuz it
was like white noise to me like I would
just play it every single night so I
could do that whole script that's fair
that's fair
Wow all right number two fear can hold
you prisoner hope can set you free
that's so generic Jack Jack Shawshank
Redemption yes correct
good guess it's very like someone came
in second okay when a series of murders
terrorized California one man took
responsible job for the mall we Joe
zodiac alright the fight for the future
begins Jack Jack Terminator 2 incorrect
resume resume Terminator 1 incorrect
wait wait hmm Lucy Lucy Independence Day
incorrect these are all good guesses
fight for the future begins quick name
any time the alternate tagline is
welcome to the real world tam dao my god
oh come on
um you know it matrix yeah
is the is the can I curse [ __ ]
tagline for the matrix seriously the
fight for the future begins not you
sucks
anyone got it there looks like they did
not good job
I like dread alright next one three
casinos I'm just gonna ruin okay Lucy
Ocean's eleven amazing heist movies in
general are just lots of fun oh yes
[Laughter]
alright the dark side of nature
Jack Jack twister yes
good lord just watch that recently some
of the CGI is rough yeah but some of us
actually pretty good I love the Netflix
warning says like warning severe weather
they're not wrong alright behind every
great love is a great story
Lucy Lucy does provide incorrect Jack
Shakespeare in Love incorrect
alternate had a headline alternate
tagline from the best-selling novel yes
this is Twilight I'm gonna bring this
here we go
don't ever talk about it Jack Fight Club
yes okay which is not the not the line
at all but okay I got to do this with a
straight face when you can live forever
what do you live for
is that a line from Hamilton yeah Jack
oh it's just time now you see Lucy
interview the vampire yes
Rochelle no Jupiter ascending he's like
that weird immortal guy or whatever any
movie about immortals
I have no idea I got this one what
weaken the shadows to steal this point
camera laughter like ten point goes to
Azra really in and YouTube chat it's
Twilight okay what kind of man would
defy a king is that just a rhetorical
question or we Joe Joe Nights tale is it
thank you yes here in Benin correct
can you say it one more time what kind
of man would defy a king the alternate
tag line is every man dies not every man
really lives
jack-jack Braveheart yes jury's spot on
that was my me doing Matt stone from
bass ketball doing milk if those
donation links are right there on your
screen or in the description box if
you're on YouTube and rich you just drop
them in the chat so thank you for that
all right as a really a good job
guessing Braveheart okay next one some
memories are best forgotten
Joe Joe Eternal Sunshine of the spotless
mind good guess not neg memento
yeah it's memento we didn't have eternal
sunshine last time and Mayor which I was
about so I thought gonna be in there I
had to get it okay seven total strangers
team up for the perfect crime they don't
know each other's name but there's
Reservoir Dogs yes violin and now sorry
use here we go get ready for the
ultimate spin exclamation point
Lucy Lucy space gem
oh my god Ben oh is it a car movie just
had twister probably not the matrix but
who knows I'm gonna say The Fast and the
Furious no that's a really good guess
seems like a tagline for the original oh
my god okay I don't know I don't know if
movie tagline posters have like this
level of pun inside them but is it
anchorman yeah no no I'm gonna wait for
the chat
unless let's see if the chat gets it
no it's gonna make you mad you're a
genius
all right I'm going to reveal the answer
in 10 seconds no it's not you or need
for speed and it's not TaleSpin blade
the movie yes you can guess good whip it
no James burden got it in the YouTube
chat is spider-man Sam Raimi's gonna
kill him something better than that but
in what way does that relate to get it
I'm not happy about it
I was refusing to reveal the alternate
tagline that was listed on art I'm Davey
but that wasn't on the poster it just
said with great power comes great zero
to hero meg Meg keep going number 15
grab life by the ball
jack jack balls of fury Meg good guess
dr. ball yes dad your wrench you can
dodge a ball yeah dodge duck dip dive
and dodge okay here we go
we're a multi-talented team the sands
will rise the heavens will part the
power will be unleashed meg Meg the
Scorpion King no Jeffrey Joe the mummy
the first one yep it is
I think it's right for you you tried to
get too clever with that one may I try
it
someone also guests who are being King
in the twitch chat so thank you we
watched a couple of weeks ago and mr.
Harry gray also got that mummy correct
cool all right next one the factory
opens July 2000 you see Charlie the
Chocolate Factory yes that is current
one charlie and the other one of it yeah
the other one was Willy Wonka and the
Chocolate Factory which world are worlds
all haters really yeah cuz he he said
that it was too like too much of a nice
movie when the real moral of the story
is that these kids are all full of being
punished buttons is more in line with I
suppose yeah I suppose so we have a
little bit under 20 minutes left in the
stream if you want to get your donations
and please do those links are on the
screen for you right there
do we have any donations Tim we do not
sadly
okay well we've got 20 minutes so that's
plenty of time to get those in all right
next question she walked off the street
into his life and still his heart
Lucy Lucy a pretty woman yes correct
okay next one life can only be
understood backwards it must be lived
forward Joe Joe Benjamin Button wait
right the quote yeah it must be lived
for but isn't the whole thing that he's
living life backward he's a baby but
he's like old and wrinkly I don't
remember it becomes a baby when he when
he's about to die yes so it okay so he's
still very insane time in like a linen
it's not a time-travel thing linear time
linear time but he ages backwards he
more physical form is like a bell curve
because he's born as a baby obvious you
know like an old baby
but then he dies as a baby again so
fight begins let's go okay something has
survived
Lucy Lucy aliens that's a really good
guess Jack Jack I guess as well the lost
world yes it is the lost world
that one yeah this is proud of you good
job all right
they saved the best trip for last but
this time they may have gone too far
the best trip the best trip Jack Jack
hangover 3 no they went too far every
one of those it could be the traveler
could be a drug thing like clowns and
banana peels
for the chat they saved the best trip
for last Back to the Future 3 yes I
guess too far yeah it was Meg saying it
could be a sci-fi thing you are giving
you half of one of my points it doesn't
affect my ranking or you you're welcome
all right next one a mother a daughter
three possible fathers maybe Meg Mamma
Mia
yeah it is courts already on their own
when you get a three-minute a baby
possible and I'm like what you gonna do
you see Lucy I'm saying it cuz in my
head I win and then in the latest boy's
movie they sing that every five minutes
so of course they do they really do meta
they're being metal all right next one
speed needs no translation
Lucy Lucy the faster Perry's Tokyo Drift
yes oh god I hope Chris and Matt are
watching Ellen's for you all right
my only love sprung from my only hate
oh my god I know this sad to hear I'm
sorry um weird that its first person
yeah my only love sprung from my only
hate not Twilight know which one I have
I've seen them all I'm afraid to say
that oh I'll help you out 1996
Jack Jack is it is it Romeo and Juliet
yes correct
I just realized I've nothing is better
than Johnny was on that movie yeah wait
can we dissect that a little bit yeah my
only love sprung from my only hate yeah
but isn't the whole point that Rome and
Julian are like indifferent to the
familial dispute like Romeo doesn't hate
them right right persons like mine
singular marketing is weird
okay here's a tough one at the edge of
the world his journey begins Rochelle
Rochelle The Truman Show good guess you
can see how that work a little-known
Truman Show sequel is it around the
world in 80 days
no I'll give a clue the years 2000
at the edge of the world his journey
begins Oh Chris Hanner said in the chat
I am proud of you Mike also Ninja
Turtles - as a bunch of fun and the only
time vanilla ice was cool Chris as usual
is right mr. Harry grey guess Waterworld
that is incorrect
[Music]
but that would not be 2004 - this
[Music]
alright one more clue a volleyball
Oh Meg Meg yes here you go choose life
choose a job choose who's getting home
Lucy transferring yes correct but which
one cold was it cool trades going to I
think I think Trainspotting again
Trainspotting still are getting TT
Trainspotting alright
the movie they're making isn't a movie
anymore Jack Rochelle is it adaptation
no Joe Tropic Thunder yes correct
I just could say Blair Witch alright
next one a diamond in the rough
Jack Jack Aladdin
yes of course great movie live-action
one's not bad
it's actually pretty good it's actually
pretty good
it's on Disney plus it's alright I got
burned by live-action Beauty and the
Beast the guy who played what's his name
in Legion
Dan Stevens the guy who played the
villain in Legion who I was obsessed
with
odd Farook yes here we go
in prison for 15 years five days five
days to seek revenge in prison 15 years
bridge oh oh boy yes
which one exact same stuff here we go an
epic of miniature proportions bridge Oh
bridge Oh mmm
it could be a couple but small silver
[Music]
Jack and temps it's horrible but
downsizing no honey i shrunk the kids
good guess oh my god someone was most
epic of mini interpretor shion's i know
i might know the circle that it's in
yeah the circle it was in was guessed
already okay
the track got it right fits Patel got it
right it is a bug's life good job
yes it is a bug's life all right
remember small soldiers though said like
I am Archer Christopher Lee did the
voice for it
oh reading yeah somebody someone had a
great voice it was a cool design there
was the one that was just like its
eyeball all make a stock Tommy Lee Jones
oh yeah Oh Tommy Lee Jones yeah correct
okay he just landed the gig of his life
fifth grade oh he just landed the gig of
his life his life meg Meg cool rock yes
yep that's a clever tagline someone took
some time and actually watched the movie
[Laughter]
[Music]
so cute alright next one in order to
break the code one man will have to
break all the rules
Oh Joe Joe DaVinci Code this is a pivot
but The Da Vinci Code was one of the
inspirations for kwibi
which I find when so much else is
resting here at all week is it hackers
no great the code has to break the rules
Oh Lucy Lucy bull game it's not a great
tagline for this film or it's not like
this I guess in order to break the code
one man will have to break all the rules
the year is 2004
the chat got it got nerd collector an
8-bit malfunction yes national treasure
correctly what great I mean I guess is
literally breaking the rules by stealing
yeah supposedly they wrote a third one
and the script exists somewhere and I
would love to read that we have five
minutes left you still can get your
donations in or go to our store and
whatever you buy will also go directly
to charity I think we got we got a
donation of $14 and 54 cents from the
Wozzeck bow again or black casting the
final stretch here is is is the are we
cemented here as far as who's in the
running is there any chance for anyone
to yeah we can do what we did last time
your probably gonna win so I'm gonna
disqualify you from the way all right so
is everyone else can stay in okay an
undercover cop in a class by himself
time Tim Kindergarten Cop yes it is hell
on heels Jack Black The Devil Wears
Prada corrects ice he doesn't play golf
he destroys it Rezac bridge oh happy go
mark correct
if you're not first you're last jacket
jack
Talladega Nights full name of that movie
The Ballad of Ricky Bobby yeah nicely
done all right boy meets girl boy falls
in love girl doesn't reach out Jeff 500
days of summer correct when where
history comes to life for job jack
Rijo uh Bill & Ted's Excellent Adventure
no Jack yeah
nice Museum correct ah just one better
yeah yeah all right I'm gonna go and see
some of my extra questions before I do
my last one since we have two minutes
left or three decades of life in the
Mafia
this can't be Meg this can't be right
Godfather Part three no good get Jack oh
is it Goodfellas yeah say that of
casinos like it's gonna be all right
these are now later than 2010 possibly
it's a mix heroes don't get any bigger
Jack Jack ant-man yes it is all right an
unforgettable journey he probably won't
remember that was an unforgettable
journey she probably won't remember uh
what's wrong with her mm Oh Oh Meg meg
oh yes
[Laughter]
don't let it in
mm thanks Meg yep that's what that kid
screamed that entire movie yeah that's
also an 8-man 3 o'clock so here's the
final one honey just got funny time Meg
yes mom our felon at the end yes so that
brings us to the end of our stream let's
announce the scores for the top three
Lucy with 57 points didn't even need
that extra bonus round at the end Jack's
your second with 53 points
oh yeah and Mike with 40 points twice as
good as last time thank you for this
time around chastity I appreciate she
blabs matter in $11 to copa90 indirect
relief and I'll have those matched by
CBS as well for all those chat points so
thank you so much you can still donate
we've got a couple more charity streams
this week
all the way through Friday at 12 p.m.
Pacific time tomorrow we have Elise and
James Williams is that correct that is
correct
oh I'm so sorry yeah join them I think
they're playing The Sims well I'm
playing The Sims and we're gonna you
know either ruin or build up a sim and
let them leave lead their best lives yes
you can donate to those same links and
also let's bring up the store one more
time store gamespot.com is where you can
get all this fine play for all merch and
all profits go to charity so go ahead
and check that out
store that gamespot.com Jack thank you
so much for joining us thank you for
having me thank you you can find me on
Twitter Jack under store P I'm also over
at roosterteeth so go hang out a rooster
teeth watch bird streaming live
constantly over there make a lot of
content awesome well thank you all for
being here and thank you guys for
watching and joining
today and we'll see you next time see ya
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]